If I should have a daughter, instead of "Mom,"...
...she's gonna call me "Point B"...
because that way she knows that no matter what happens,...
...at least she can always find her way to me.
And I'm gonna paint the solar systems on the backs of her hands...
...so she has to learn the entire universe before she can say,...
"Oh, I know that like the back of my hand."
And she's gonna learn that this life will hit you hard in the face,...
...wait for you to get back up just so it can kick you in the stomach.
But getting the wind knocked out of you is the only way to remind your lungs...
...how much they like the taste of air.
"Baby," I'll tell her,...
"Remember, your mama is a worrier and your papa is a warrior..."
"...and you are the girl with small hands and big eyes..."
"...who never stops asking for more."
Remember that good things come in threes and so do bad things.
Always apologize when you've done something wrong,...
...but don't you ever apologize for the way your eyes refuse to stop shining.
Your voice is small, but don't ever stop singing.
And when they finally hand you heartache,...
...when they slip war and hatred under your door...
...and offer you handouts on street corners of cynicism and defeat,...
...you tell them that they really ought to meet your mother.